para conversar sobre este tema hemos
invitado a Alejandra González guerrera
ella es candidata a doctora en ciencias
políticas especialista en asuntos de
género contextos violentos y también en
medio oriente ella se encuentra en la
Ciudad de México Alejandra Bienvenida al
programa Gracias por estar con nosotros
Muchas gracias por la invitación
Alejandra quiero comenzar preguntándole
por las impresiones generales que usted
tiene y el análisis que se puede hacer
de el papel de la mujer en la actualidad
en Arabia Saudita a raíz de esta pequeña
apertura que ha tenido el país a nivel
cultural y sobre todo esos pequeños
espacios que le ha empezado a conceder a
la mujer
justamente la palabra la palabra
correcta es concesión porque han habido
pequeños guiños de apertura no como
dejarlas entrar a estadios o dejarlas
manejar usar motos pero
pues siguen siendo ciudadanas
llamémoslas de segunda no no tienen
total acceso a los derechos a pesar de
que Arabia ratificó no tienen no tienen
pleno acceso a los derechos no tienen
igualdad
no no hay gran acceso a a trabajos o
libertades básicas como elegir la ropa
pero poco a poco estos lugares se van
ganando por medio de activismos de
luchas y también depresiones externas
que que estas han sido muy importantes
con con el con el príncipe
ha presionado estos estos pequeños
cambios Alejandra justamente le quería
preguntar por estos logros estas
concesiones que tienen ahora las mujeres
a llenar Arabia Saudita se dan a través
de luchas por parte de los colectivos
femeninos si es que los haya llenarías
Saudita se da por presión internacional
o esto cabe dentro del Marco que está
viviendo el país de esta apertura a todo
nivel como lo decíamos en la
introducción del programa
es una combinación de todas la
organización feminista dentro del país
es prácticamente imposible no pero si
hay desde desde el exterior de la
diáspora grandes presiones para esos
cambios y también
las políticas internacionales para que
Arabia saudi forme parte de ciertos
grupos necesita tener cambios cambios al
interior lo de los estadios vuelvo a
esto
parece niño pero la FIFA no permite que
ningún país sea parte de de de la
organización sino las mujeres no pueden
entrar a los estadios que eso lo vimos
con Irán en el en el último mundial no
iban a perder su su boleto porque no
dejaron entrar a las mujeres Entonces
estas presiones externas ayudan
muchísimo y también esta nueva imagen
que se pretende dar de del país
con al exterior
Alejandra Cómo entender esa imagen que
está queriendo vender Arabia Saudita al
exterior un país como lo decíamos en la
introducción del programa que quiere
venderse de una manera diferente Pero No
necesariamente de la forma en que
occidente quiere que sea este país o que
comprenda el sentimiento occidental de
cómo debe ser el rol de una mujer en ese
orden de ideas mi pregunta va dirigida a
cómo Entonces es la imagen de la mujer
que quiere vender Arabia Saudita en este
nuevo escenario en este nuevo contexto
Bueno lo lo primero y y
está en las leyes no la mujer debe estar
dentro de su casa debe formar a una
familia la la primer función de una
mujer para los audios al interior es ser
madre y estar a cargo del espacio
privado pero también con con esta imagen
que necesita dar está teniendo estos
pequeños niños de apertura entonces
Bueno sí que les permite ir al cine pero
para lograr que una mujer dirija una
película lo tiene que hacer escondidas
como como pasó con no entonces
y hay apertura pero pero son son guiños
casi como
como para cumplir con los requisitos no
para realmente
hacer que las mujeres sean parte de la
vida social y política de
no tener una actividad social no tienen
un rol definido en la política o bueno
no existe un rol de la mujer en la
política de ese país Aquí puede ver uno
y han sido parte también de estas
críticas que hace la comunidad
internacional Arabia sauditas justamente
Pues esa falta de rol que se le puede
dar a la mujer y a otros colectivos al
interior de la sociedad Saudita pero lo
que uno ve desde occidente es que como
hay una inmensa y millonaria industria
petrolera de por medio las críticas o
por lo menos la recriminación a nivel
internacional No es igual no es con el
mismo rasero que se mira Arabia Saudita
como se mide a otros países de la
comunidad internacional que no tienen
tantos recursos aquí que crítica se le
puede hacer a organismos internacionales
y a la sociedad por digamos ser
cómplices puede ser la palabra tal vez
Alejandra de de esta disminución de la
mujer en esta sociedad
Bueno claro que lalia no no solo los los
el poderío económico que tiene que tiene
sabor por las grandes reservas de
petróleo sino también la alianza
estratégica que tiene con ciertas
potencias en en occidente y también en
Oriente con china también tiene tiene
cierta ciertas alianzas entonces Esto
hace que Las observaciones que se hacen
desde desde occidente sean mucho más
acotadas mucho más restringidas y sean
solo como tal observaciones no no se
apunte
aunque son países muy distintos con
contextos y situaciones políticas y
sociales y desarrollo histórico muy
distinto las situaciones de las mujeres
iraníes y saudis en cierto punto Se
podrían comparar pero no es comparable
la
la presión internacional que tiene el
gobierno iraní que tiene el gobierno
saudí para impulsar la igualdad política
social laboral y económica de mujeres en
nuestros países Alejandro usted menciona
otro caso muy particular del mundo
musulmán y es el caso de Irán allí en
los últimos meses sí que hemos visto a
colectivos de mujeres a grupos de ellas
y de otros ciudadanos salir a las calles
para pedir reivindicar ciertos derechos
de la mujer en Irán pero si uno compara
irán con Arabia Saudita el papel de la
mujer es mucho más abierto en Irán las
mujeres pueden ir a estudiar pueden
desplazarse con cierta libertad Hasta
cierto punto dentro del país se les
obliga a tener un comportamiento pero si
uno compara los dos roles de la mujer
son completamente distintos entendiendo
también que dentro del mundo musulmán
son países enemigos Cómo puede uno
diferenciar esos dos roles y esas dos
luchas que al final del túnel se juntan
bueno justamente estos estos dos países
que se podrían comparar
fácilmente pero vienen de momentos
distintos la islamización del espacio
público en Irán ocurrió como una
respuesta a a una Revolución antes del
79 el espacio público en Irán era
distinto de hecho incluso hubo
prohibición del velo pero a partir de la
revolución del 79 y la islamización del
país es que se impone cierta vestimenta
a las mujeres pero no es exactamente
el el vestuario que se debe usar en
cambio
se tiene que usar por completo La valla
y tiene que cubrir por completo de una
forma en específica en Irán solo se
tiene que usar el velo y seguir el de
cierta forma No tiene que ser luchador
pero también Irán como como explico Esta
es una respuesta un movimiento a un
movimiento político y social en cambio
no nunca ha tenido una Revolución y
nunca ha tenido un cambio político desde
desde la fundación en 1932 del reino de
de Arabia saudi no ha habido ningún
ninguna revuelta ninguna protesta que
Perdón que le signifique algún riesgo al
régimen en el gobierno claro justamente
otro de los de las aristas que tiene
este reportaje es la industria
cinematográfica naciente que tiene este
país en donde la mujer también está
empezando a tener ciertos roles
destacados tanto a nivel actoral como a
nivel de producción a nivel de dirección
hay quienes creen que este desarrollo y
esta Apuesta por la industria
cinematográfica es precisamente para
para darle a los ciudadanos un poco de
aire un poco de oxígeno a raíz de esos
escenarios de manifestaciones que vimos
en el marco de la primavera árabe un
escenario que Arabia Saudita no quiere
llegar a ver justamente por esa
represión tan fuerte que se vive allí
Esta es una estrategia que está
funcionando le allí a la casa real de
Arabia Saudita para para mitigar ese
impacto de las manifestaciones como
usted menciona que ha tenido lugar en
Irán y en otros países como Libia
incluso Siria
bueno el cine también tiene tiene
funciones hacia afuera y hacia dentro
del país hacia dentro del país sirve
como escapatoria que las como se ven al
reportaje las mujeres yendo por primera
vez al cine es impresionante además el
ritual de ir a este dar una película en
una sala de cine es sumamente
impresionante y es parte
y saca de la realidad no una pantalla
blanca que en ese vacío permite expectar
Lo que sea está llena de de
imposibilidades es maravilloso no
entonces hacia dentro del país es ese
momento escapatoria es tener
representaciones de de ciertas cosas
identificaciones y bueno todo lo que
sabemos que el cine nos no significa
como como como como como obra de arte
pero también hacia afuera cuenta una
historia el cine nacional oficial se
suele usar como
pero también para contar lo que se
quiere que se sepa en el exterior no lo
vemos muy bien con el ejemplo de Corea
del Sur el cine de Corea del Sur y y el
k-pop nos ha hecho voltear hacia un país
que no estaba realmente en
en la mente de los habitantes de el
resto del mundo Alejandra a mí la
sensación que me deja este desarrollo de
esta industria cinematográfica
llenarábia Saudita Es que creo que ya
tiene muy claro Cuál es el poder el
alcance que tiene el cine como un medio
de comunicación masivo de
entretenimiento Pero también tiene muy
claro que además de ser una ventana
hacia el exterior para mostrar esos
cambios en Arabia Saudita también es un
mecanismo para difundir la propaganda
Estatal y enviar ese mensaje certero a
la audiencia camuflado dentro de una
historia y dentro de una de una
atmósfera de entretenimiento y esto
sobrepasa esas críticas de censura y de
represión que hay hacia Arabia Saudita
Esto no es lo mismo pero mostrado de una
manera diferente
y claro o sea el el cine de hecho como
se ve en el reportaje
está sumamente cuidado hay libertad de
representación pero no de expresión
Claro que pueden representar y claro que
pueden contar historias pero la historia
tiene que ser la que desde la
oficialidad se permite
Alejandra allí al interior de la
sociedad Saudita es un país con una
realidad muy ajena América Latina y tal
vez hay preguntas que se salen un poco
de la historia que les presentamos en el
en el en el reportaje pero quiero que
vale la pena ponerlo en contexto para la
para la audiencia en América Latina y es
al interior de este país donde hay una
familia real una monarquía con poder
absoluto y a raíz de esta apertura hacia
el mundo
internacional en general porque no
solamente hacia occidente sino también
hacia usted ya lo decía hacia china por
ejemplo se han empezado a presentar
algunas tensiones sobre todo a nivel
religioso qué tan alta y qué tan
preocupante es la tensión religiosa en
un país religioso desde la médula per se
bueno para empezar hay que mencionar que
el el islam que se practica en en Arabia
saudí es el islam summing que a
diferencia de Irán es el Irán si
practica el chip Pero en la línea del
surismo ellos practican o ellos llevan
el Abismo Qué es
sumamente conservador y que no permite
la interpretación de hecho se le ha
llamado el islam puro Por qué no hay
adaptación ni interpretación de la
revelación como tal o de lo que se
interpreta como la revelación y la
sharía es el la ley islámica que hace a
partir del Corán los dichos y hechos del
profeta que son los los jarices y las
fatuas que se hace que lo hacen expertos
de la ley
no hay interpretación Entonces se tiene
que seguir el islam puro como ellos
interpretan que es el islam puro pero
por ejemplo el velo en el Corán no está
mencionado que se tiene que usar un tipo
específico de velo se habla de que tiene
las mujeres y los hombres se tienen que
cubrir de una forma Modesta
Y eso se interpreta según
la regionalidad la modestia se
interpreta de ciertas formas Pero
Entonces
el régimen al ser tan conservador
cualquier signo o símbolo de apertura le
significa a ellos una una amenaza Porque
no solo sería cambiar el régimen para
para ellos el la religión y la política
están completamente implicados pero es
una versión de la religión no hay
aceptación de otras formas claro aquí lo
que uno ve también Alejandra es que
décadas atrás antes de esta apertura lo
censurados los perseguidos y reprimidos
eran los ciudadanos que tenían que
someterse a unas leyes del estado ahora
con esta apertura y Pese a que muchos
sectores religiosos no están de acuerdo
con el rey y no aceptan esta apertura él
lo ha defendido A capa y espada para
imponerlo a los ciudadanos y ahora son
los religiosos los que parecen ser los
perseguidos por no aceptar este tipo de
cambios volteó la moneda a nivel social
esto hacia futuro qué repercusiones
puede traer
Pues los religiosos ahora se han
perseguidos sino que no son del todo
escuchados son accionarios ante los
pequeños guiños de cambio como tal que
las mujeres puedan votar que
en Latinoamérica Pues nos suena como
como una casi locura con las mujeres no
puedan votar no las mujeres saudi tienen
11 años votando
Y eso eso para la reacción conservadora
de los de los religiosos
pues es una gran gran ofensa porque es
darle voz a lo que ellos consideran
objetos no sujetos de derechos políticos
es Claro ese punto Alejandra para ir
terminando llegamos Ya básicamente al
bloque final de este análisis sobre este
reportaje aquí en reportajes en
reporteros Plus en France 24 Qué futuro
le espera entonces a la mujer en Arabia
Saudita más apertura más roles definidos
o una interpretación de una mujer del
ámbito musulmán que solamente se adapta
a estas condiciones de Arabia Saudita
Pues también de qué mujeres estamos
hablando las mujeres de la élite que
tienen ciertas posibilidades que hasta
hace cinco años que no podían manejar
ellas podrían pagar mucho
Está hablando de otras condiciones pero
pues también otros otras mujeres que no
no pertenecen a la familia o que no
pertenecen a las élites económicas Pues
tampoco tienen grandes posibilidades lo
que lo que estos pequeños guiños de
cambio pueden
pueden ser la semilla que siempre la
necesidad de cambio dentro de la
sociedad pero
Esto será a muy largo plazo por
justamente el gran control
dentro dentro del país y quiénes son
sujetos de derechos dentro del país
Alejandra pues muchas gracias por este
análisis por habernos puesto en
perspectiva el rol de la mujer de la
industria cinematográfica como medio de
comunicación masivo para llegar a los
ciudadanos en esta nueva estrategia que
tiene el gobierno la casa real allí en
Arabia Saudita una realidad muy distinta
a la que vivimos en América Latina pero
que vale la pena entender No entenderla
desde nuestra óptica sino entendiendo la
coyuntura y la realidad que se vive en
este país Muchísimas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros
Muchas gracias por la invitación y
gracias a ustedes por habernos
acompañado la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Jennifer Guevara y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera es todo por hoy pueden
continuar en sintonía de France 24 y
también encuentro más información en
cuatro punto com dejen sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]